You're an interesting man
in Scott Lang.
I don't know who you are, but
you've made a big mistake.
Okay?
I'm an Avenger.
I've called the other Avengers
the only Avenger.
Have I killed you before?
what?
They all bleed together after a while.
You're not the one with the hammer.
It's Thor.
We get confused like similar body types.
Who are you?
Just a man
who's lost a lot of time like you.
But we can help each other with that.
A lot has changed about my life.
We literally saved the world.
But right now,
the only job I want is being a dad.
Scotland.
Do you want to get out of here
and I need to get out of here.
Bring me what I want. What's that?
You got.
Come down.
You cannot trust him.
Well, I ain't going to.
I don't care who this guy is.
I just lost so much time.
Oh, I find about your job is a monster.
He thinks he's bigger.
Everything you call a life,
I will burn out of time.
He's got Cassie stop together.
You think you can beat me?
Welcome back, everyone.
Is Charlie Marvel dropped a bunch
of new scenes of Ant-Man and the wasp.
Quantumania. Yeah, with Kang
talking about fighting the other
Avengers, the Kang Multiverse War.
I'll explain how this all ties in
with Loki Season two,
because he talks very literally
about killing versions of Thor.
That's our connection to Loki.
I know everybody's wondering if there's
going to be a Loki cameo during the movie,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we're doing in IMAX
to give away for the movie.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with Kang during Loki Season two,
I literally just did a Loki Season
two video,
so I'll post a link at the end of this
in the description below
because we're going to see a bunch of Kang
variants during that different
from this Kang variant.
This Kang variant is meant to be
the worst of all the Kang variants
who is exiled from the Council of Kangs
when he's talking to Scott Lang
about being confused?
He's killed so many variants
of the Avengers
teams from across so many universes.
He's referring to the original Kang
Multiverse War, meaning
he is from the original timeline.
I'm sure there'll be a bunch of questions
about this
when the movie actually comes out.
I will do a bunch
more videos in the next week.
I think I'm allowed to post
my non spoiler review next Tuesday,
so be sure to look out for that.
But the basic idea for
he who remains in the original timeline,
which we haven't seen, the sacred
timeline is technically
like the new version
of another variant of Kang.
Who is he Who remains?
He who remains isn't the original Kang
from the 616 Marvel Universe.
He's just the Kang
that won the Multiverse war
that first time
in the very first timeline,
like the original timeline of the 616
Marvel Earth in the 30th century.
Nathaniel
Richards is born in this advanced society.
It's called the time of plenty.
There is no want for anything.
Everyone can cure every disease easily.
There's no hunger. There's no poverty.
It is the most boring version of reality
you could possibly imagine.
He gets really bored and starts
using science
to try and find other universes in per
he who remains that Nathaniel
Richards learned about the multiverse.
Then over time, other variants of Kang
from other universes
did the same thing,
and they formed the Council of Kangs.
And for a time
there was peace in the multiverse.
They worked for the betterment of each
other's universes, sharing technology,
everything was great.
Eventually, the Kang the Conqueror
variant of Nathaniel Richards rose up
the one that we see in Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania.
He's meant to be the worst
variant of the character.
The way he talks about it
to many of the other characters
in the other clips
in the way that Kevin Foggy talks about
the character in that original Timeline
version of the Council of Kangs,
He went so crazy
trying to conquer other universes
that the rest of the Council of Kangs
exiled him to the quantum realm.
There was a question early on
as to how he wound up there
in the first place,
and Janet Van Dyne found him.
Did he crash there the first time?
This makes more sense
that the Council of Kangs specifically
stranded him there on purpose,
and it was meant to be a makeshift prison
for him outside of the normal time space.
The way that Marvel's
clarifying the quantum realm as it exists
relative to the rest of the multiverse
is that it's sort of like a substrate that
exists outside of the normal space time.
So when he remains one,
the Kang Multiverse War
and they stopped fighting
and it was just the sacred timeline.
The quantum realm didn't change.
It wasn't affected by all those changes
in the different timelines
or the erasure of other universes.
So all that time, while
the Kang Multiverse War was playing out,
he who remains, was using Elias to win it.
This exiled Kang the Conqueror variant,
which is stewing in his own self,
getting more and more pissed off.
In the other clips
he talks about getting revenge and burning
those that exiled him out of time,
basically going to get revenge
on the rest of the Council of Kangs.
That's really what sets him
apart from characters like Thanos.
Like Thanos
wanted to change the main universe.
It was really just one universe,
and he wasn't really concerned
with other versions of himself.
Kang is a man at war with himself
as much as he's at war with the other
Avengers, very literally at war
with other versions of himself.
Then, after he was exiled,
what happened is enough time went by.
Eventually, Janet Van
Dyne was stranded there and found him
and he just lied to her
and tried to find a way to use her
technology in pym particles
to escape the quantum realm.
And then he could go back to conquering
the rest of the multiverse wall
that was happening.
Janet Van Dyne learned
the truth of what was going on in
Stranded in There by taking out the engine
from his time travel chair.
This is actually based on the comic book
version of his clamshell time travel ship.
Two villains
always had the Comfiest chairs.
And does this not look like
he totally stole the idea from Grogu?
This looks like a giant version, like
a giant villain version of Grogan's Pod.
I've talked about this
in my previous videos too.
There's all kinds of Doctor Doom
Easter eggs in here too,
especially for his comic book BackStory.
A lot of Kang's technology
initially was based on ideas
that Doctor Doom came up with
in the first place.
Like originally Kang's first time
travel machine he found in a museum
for Doctor Doom, he found a doom board
and it alerted him to all these archives
that he then restored.
He found the plans for Doctor Doom's time
travel platform, enhance them
with his future technology
from the 13th century,
and used that to create a sphinx ship
to go back in time and become the Rama
version of the character.
And even though
they're talking about this Kang
the Conqueror variant
going up against the Council of Kangs,
we'll see a much bigger version
of the Kang
multiverse War play out in him,
going up against other versions
of Avengers killing,
other variants of Avengers.
When we get to Avengers five Qing Dynasty
in, then obviously you have Avengers
six Secret Wars where you have a bunch
of multiverse characters fighting him.
The rumor right now
is that by the time we get to Avengers
six Secret
Wars, it'll be a different villain.
It'll be like a beyond or variant of Kang
because isn't that kind of the joke
of this whole situation here?
The whole idea
is that The Avengers, in other realities,
were not powerful enough to stop Kang.
The only person who can kill Kang
is another Kang.
There have been all kinds of crazy rumors
about Avengers secret wars,
even the fact that Marvel
might split it into two movies
just because they're looking to earn
so much more money quickly
in the next couple of years. In Avengers,
movies
are kind of like licenses
for Disney and Marvel to print money.
So the bigger
they can go, the more money they can earn
in, the longer they can keep Doing that
just means more dump trucks of money year
after year for them.
We'll see how that winds up playing out.
Like as long as the story is cool,
I don't care how many movies
they want to do.
They could do six movies,
four secret wars that they want to.
That's how big it is.
If they did
like a 12 hour version of Secret Wars,
they would still be cutting out a whole
bunch of really cool comic book stuff.
And when we start talking about
Loki season two,
the other Thor related characters,
we're supposed to see a bunch of other
variants of Kang during Loki Season two,
but in terms of which versions we see,
they'll be all over the spectrum
and it won't just be
the comic book versions
because there are only a handful
of different comic book
versions of the character
because it's all the same.
Kang From
just different parts of his timeline.
Really good example of
this is I think they're going to pay off
the Easter egg about QENG Industries,
which was a version of Kang
that came back in the present day
and pretended to be a businessman.
And you see his name
on the Avengers tower here.
So like the he who remains, Kang found
that another variant of Kang had rose up
and tried to become this businessman,
replacing The Avengers in this reality,
and he obviously pruned him
and sent him to be eaten by a lion.
I think amongst the many variants of Kang
will be seeing that variant of Kang.
So it's just a really good example of like
the many different types of characters
we'll see him playing.
Usually when people think of different
variants of Kang,
they just think of the big ones,
like the Immortals version.
That was kind of he who remains.
There's the Kang
the Conqueror version during Ant-Man
and the wasp, like the main version,
but also the Scarlet Centurion.
You also have the Kid Kang
Iron Lad version of the character.
Really interested to see if any of the
theories about that character pan out.
There's a lot of theories
that we'll see, like a younger actor
pretending to be someone else in the MCU.
Like they could do that for Ironheart.
They could do that for Black Panther's
son, Prince T'Challa.
The basic idea
is that by the time we get to Avengers
five Qing Dynasty,
we'll see a bunch more variants.
The other cool thing
you see going on in the background,
a lot of these scenes
I haven't talked a lot about is Cassie
laying in her Stinger gear in the comics.
She's gone by a couple of different names.
The Stinger name is the one
with the purple suit.
Her powers are a little bit closer
to the wasp's powers.
There was a bunch of other young Avengers
footage that they released,
so I'll do a new video for that
in the next couple of days too.
There's a bunch of big Super Bowl trailers
dropping this weekend.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those.
I'll do videos for everything.
It'll probably take me
a couple of days to get through them
all, but should start on Sunday.
I think we're getting a Guardians
of the Galaxy
three trailer, a new Ant-Man
and the wasp Quantumania trailer,
maybe a trailer for the Marvel's movie,
and maybe a couple of other surprises.
And then there's some DC trailers, too.
Separately,
everyone click here for my new Loki Season
two trailer video and click here to learn
about Kang starting the Multiverse
war in the first place.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.